- It's all in my head.
I got it.
I just got to put pen to paper.
We got this.
We can really win this game.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday
morning of your life?
("Better For It"
by Foreign Air)
Asked to work a lot which is
what I would say is
when it falls in to work
that's in-between what
VaynerMedia does or another
digital agency does and what a
Boston Consulting Group,
Bain does
around transformational
digital, right?
So internet of things,
top level domain,
new emerging things or
even like hard core you
know what's our Facebook video
strategy to replace television
commercials and make it a
Facebook environment.
You know, things like that.
A lot of heavier thinkin.
Another day of filming.
(bell dings)
Am I free? Am I free?
- Yes, you're free.
- [Gary] Huge.
I appreciate it.
You gonna be okay with that?
- [Jason] First year,
you helped me kick off
a piece a day project.
Second year, you helped me
again kick off piece a week.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I learned a lot both times.
Natural progression is to go one
a month but to go as deep as you
can fucking go with a piece and
what I want to do is collaborate
every single month
with a different person.
I want to sit down and say,
okay, so kick it off with you
and say, "This is gonna
be a Vaynerchuk piece.
"I want to sit down
say 20, 30 minutes.
"Talk to you."
- [Gary] Or with some people
that have more time than me sit
down for two, three hours.
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] Or two days.
- Honestly, someone
like you I could--
- Two days.
- [Jason] Totally, totally.
Extract from video and then
reduce that message 'cause
what I found is powerful
about the shit I do
is I can reduce a story--
- In to a piece.
You're a storyteller, right.
The way that I'm a storyteller
in my way, you are in your way.
- [Jason] Exactly.
Dude, I appreciate the time.
- [Gary] I love you, man.
Good luck to you.
- Look, you guys be well.
- [DRock] You too.
- Planet of the Apps, all that.
DRock, rock on, brother.
- [Gary] A lot going on.
104's done?
- [Woman On Phone] Hello?
- Hey.
- [Woman On Phone] How are you?
- I'm really well.
How are you?
- [Woman On Phone] I'm
trying not to freak out.
- [Gary] (laughs)
That's a good strategy.
We don't want to spend our
entire 60 Second Club
on the freak out.
- No, no, not at all.
- [Gary] Very cool so what do
you want to do in our time here?
- I actually wanted to know,
I know that in a couple of your
Snaps you said you have a family
and I know you don't show your
kids on Snap and
stuff like that.
But I'm just curious on
how you balance it all.
I kind of do a couple different
things and for a while there
I kind of felt like I had
everything at
least up in the air.
And then it kind of all came
down and now just trying to get
everything spinning again.
I just feel like if I'm doing
good on one then I'm failing at
another and I just want to
know how you balance it all.
- [Gary] I think I balance it
all by not judging
myself too harshly.
I think that's really
where it starts and stops.
I think way too many people
have lost the work-life balance
before it's even started because
they're gonna be critical on
themselves regardless of it.
Right, it's so hard to balance
and so for me I just know I'm
doing the best that I can and
if I'm doing the best that I can
that in itself has put me
in a position to succeed.
And some days that means that
I have to choose my family time
on a Friday night or Sunday
morning, an executive ran into
me on Saturday and asked me to
meet for coffee and wanted to
jam and I just couldn't.
I couldn't because of
the family time, right?
And so that's the
family being chosen.
Other times I'm flying and
speaking somewhere or having a
big meeting and I'm missing you
know some sort of like school
function that I didn't want to
miss and that's the other way
and the truth is I just
don't beat myself up.
All of us are trying the best we
can and so as long as nothing is
glaring and to me
glaring is the following:
my kids have become
completely horrible people and
have major problems in society
and/or I go directly out of
business in my businesses.
As long as neither one of those
are happening I think
it's gonna be okay.
And so I think it's how you
judge how you're balancing way
more than the reality of it
and recognizing that you have a
different point of view
on it then your partner,
then the kids, then your
business associates and
I think you need to care
about your point of view
on it first and foremost while
being empathetic to
everybody else's points of view.
- [Woman On Phone] Awesome.
(laughs)
That's a really good answer.
I know that, yeah, it's hard to
try and not judge what you're
doing and stuff like that.
- That's the game, right?
That's, like, everybody could be
failing at work-life balance if
they've decided that they're
failing at work-life balance.
- [Woman On Phone] Okay.
- So, as long as you know you're
not, as long as your spouse or
your partner isn't saying I want
to break up or get a divorce and
as long as your kids aren't
eating pine tar and as long as
your banks aren't coming to
foreclosure your business,
you're gonna be okay.
You know and I think people are
freaking out like I didn't even
see my dad until I was 15
and I love him and we
have the best relationship.
There're people who've had their
fathers walk out of their family
and they didn't see them for
15 years and now they've great
relationships
because they reconciled.
People are way too judgmental
and overanalyzing work-life
balance in today's
modern PR society.
- [Woman On Phone] Mhmmm.
- And so, if you feel good about
it then you'll win and I think
not judging yourself too harshly
because it is hard to balance
everything 'cause
that's life and I just
I don't aim for perfect.
I'm not interested in
perfect, it's not real.
Perfect is fake
and so I just live.
- [Woman On Phone]
That's awesome.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
It feels better, right?
It feels better to
look at it that way.
- [Woman On Phone] Yeah,
I said it's hard and with little
kids and stuff, you know
it's like Mommy's not here,
Daddy's not here and that's
kind of all they see.
You know as much as they're
involved it's just kind
of hard some days.
- They're tougher
tougher than you think.
How old are they?
- [Woman On Phone]
Three and eight.
- Three and eight,
tell me anything you
remember being three. Go.
- [Woman On Phone] Not much.
(laughs)
- Interesting.
- [Woman On Phone]
Just being in a hospital.
- Right.
And you know what?
As long as you're counter
balancing it with love and one
of the biggest things, all these
parents judging people meanwhile
they're around 'cause they
work 9 to 5 but if they're not
deploying love and are in it
from 5 to 9 every night and on
the weekend what are
they really accomplishing?
Just 'cause you're there
doesn't mean you're there.
- [Woman On Phone] Right.
When you do have your family,
like you said, when you have
your family time you just kind
of say that's family time and
that's kind of non-negotiable.
That might be
different times but...
- Yes and sometimes,
most the time it works out but
some times it doesn't, right?
Sometimes I can get distracted
and I'm just not willing to beat
myself up if I decided to go
down a rabbit hole for an hour
on a Sunday when I should've
been all-in on the family.
That's just gonna happen.
I just--
- [Woman On Phone] Right.
- This is about not beating
yourself up and knowing where
your intent and your efforts are
and also knowing
life's a long game.
So in two, three years when I'm
taking my kids on business trips
and traveling with them and
showing them the world like
that's where the benefits
have come from
some of the sacrifices.
I don't know, I think everybody,
you know, if they had the option
of would you rather have had
your parents around every minute
from 1 to 5 but not be able to
do all these amazing experiences
with them from 11 to 18 versus
the alternative, I just have a
funny feeling all this will
raise her hand and say I'll take
that 11 to 18 shit and I plan on
dominating that and some of the
sacrifices I have to create
between 1 to 8 is something
I'm willing to do and that's my
strategy and I don't give a fuck
if some parenting blogger says
that I'm not spending enough
time with them. Fuck you.
- [Woman On Phone]
(laughs) Thank you, very much.
- Let me judge you from afar.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Woman On Phone] Yeah.
Yeah, there's too many
people out there doing that.
I love your attitude and
I love your message and
I started following you
a couple months ago, I love,
I wait for your
content every day.
In fact, there's some days
that I know like, I know that
sometimes if someone's like,
"I don't have time," and this
and that you're like, "I'm gonna
go audit their social media."
And I'm like maybe I can piss
him off (Gary laughs) my
social media. (laughs)
- I love it.
- [Woman On Phone] The good or
bad I'm doing at this point but
I really appreciate
you taking the time.
In fact, I was running from
my daughter's dance lesson
with her yesterday as
I'm commenting on your
post and hash tagging and
I got home and I was like,
"I get to talk to GaryVee!"
And my husband's like,
"I don't know what that means."
- (laughs) He's like,
"What's that?"
Listen, honestly, and thank you.
Right now, I'm feeling really
good in my stomach because
I knew why I wanted to do this
60 Seconds, you know, I figured
out my health by tricking
myself into a system where I was
accountable to somebody else.
I knew that I wanted to do
something more for my community
even though that I feel like I'm
at the top of my game, I wanted
to be better than my best self
and I needed to trick myself
into a game that
made me bring more.
And at this moment, right
now, I'm super, I've never been
happier about this 60 Second.
You know, the 60 Second Club is
fun 'cause it's fun to see how
many comments and you get in
this and it's crazy and that's
all fun but this
chat made it better.
- [Woman On Phone]
Well, thank you very much.
I appreciate you taking time.
- Take care. Bye-bye.
- [Woman On Phone] Bye.
- That was fun.
- [Tyler] That was good.
You want to go?
- 60 Second Club.
Got to trick yourself.
Just need to be
smart about that.
We're going heavy
up front on that.
I'm not sure that's right.
Thoughts?
- [Jon] My thought is we need
to position how we're different
than holding companies from a
workflow perspective but say
that we're still a, call
ourselves an agency 'cause
that's what we are.
- I mean we are an agency.
- [Marcus] And I do think the
point of essentially us saying
we are better aligned than other
agencies is still
a super valid point.
I think it actually
carries a lot of weight.
- I do too, I just wonder if
it's something I talk over to
and we just show that we're the
best modern day digital agency
in the world. You know?
I'm just debating that.
- [Marcus] Yep.
- And I actually think that
sells better but I'm
still consuming this.
Keep going.
- [Marcus] So I think the
initial push from this guy was
that this was the deck that was
supposed to sell without you.
- Right, so I'm just wondering
if that's even something we want
to, how do we even sell that
without me is something
worth debating.
- I feel comfortable selling.
- [Marcus] I don't think
that's a hard story to tell.
- Okay.
I don't think it's a hard
story to tell, yeah I guess.
I guess, okay, let's keep going.
- [Marcus] I feel you
bring bravado to it
it's what I'm doing.
- Cool, so then we go in
defining what a full stack
agency is so it's consumer
attention marries the fact that
we constantly change,
we're not married to
any specific channels.
So this is where we feel like
we need to kind of stat dump and
back up the fact that we say
what we're saying with
recent statistics and facts so
consumer attention is
fragmented across channels.
Have some facts
here to back that up.
- Okay.
- With new channels arriving
ever faster is where we show
adoption on those channels is
happening at scale so quickly.
Stand alone.
- Yeah, it's gonna end up being.
- Yeah.
- [Wendi] I'm sorry, I didn't
think you were done.
- No worries, thank you so much.
- [Wendi] I'll wait 'til you
finish and then get more.
- It's a lot less today.
I think the place that we will
get even more reaction
is if this said it's time to stop
making commercials and
deploying digital 1.0 behavior.
Where I get a lot of traction is
I'm not even going to bother
you about commercials.
Let's talk about the fact
that everything you're doing is
banner and search and
you're not even adapting
to the modern web.
It's time to stop making
TV commercials
and deploying
1999 through 2010
digital behavior.
That will work and obviously
we can tweak that a little bit
but that's the energy.
It will work.
- [Marcus] Just to be clear,
we're getting rid of the
1999 to 2010, right?
- Correct. This slide says,
"It's time to stop
making TV commercials."
Right?
- [Marcus] Yeah, I think, yeah.
I think it's the
word "deploying."
It would be like we're,
"discarding" I think
would be the word.
- Got it. Yeah. Okay.
I'm just looking at
the case studies.
One thing that I want
to talk about is...
I don't like this slide so much.
I don't think it's
a big enough disparity,
I don't like it at all.
I'm just talking
about the Honey Empire.
One thing we don't talk about
is how we think about images on
Facebook and Instagram as print
and billboards and banners,
like the modern way of doing it.
It's another way to do more of
that work that I believe in and
just something that
doesn't come across here.
Shows our other
capabilities besides video.
So, just
something to think about.
- [Jon] Okay.
- I also like some of
the VaynerSmart work.
Oh, it's right here.
Got it. Good, okay.
- As far as like the new
place to spend your money.
- [Gary] Those are the
two things that stand out.
- Okay.
- That and probably
our favorite videos.
Don't we have some other CPG
videos that we can feel good
about in some way?
- [Marcus] Yeah, we
could show Swedish Fish.
- Yes!
- [Marcus] ICC.
- We're showing ICC.
I really like Swedish Fish
and another video,
another slide that
I think would work.
We've made the modern TV
commercial AKA Facebook videos
for all of these brands and
then have little screen shots of
Mountain Dew, the logo of
Mountain Dew and a
screen shot from the video.
Just and overwhelming
showing we're doing this a lot.
Anybody we've
made a Facebook video for,
I think we should show.
In the same way we used to use
logos as these are our clients.
- [Marcus] That's interesting.
- You see where I'm going?
That will really drill it home.
- [Marcus] A collage?
- Yeah.
- I'm also realizing we don't
have any Chase work in
here which is a miss.
- Right and we have
great videos for Chase.
All of it.
- Yeah.
- Let's get every video, every
single logo that we've done a
Facebook video for I want and if
it takes two slides because we
show 18 screen shots
and 18 logos
and the next one is
18 and 18, Mazel Tov.
I want them to understand
everybody's doing it and
we're the kings of it.
Those Facebook video drive home
and then a much deeper oomph to
our media capabilities.
And that's that.
- [Marcus] Great.
- Okay.
- Okay. Show me the next
version when you get a chance.
- Cool.
Alright, I feel like we can make
these pretty quickly
too which is good.
- [Marcus] Yeah.
- Okay, thanks guys.
- Thanks.
- [Marcus] Alright,
thanks for everything.
- Why did PewDiePie
close down his YouTube?
It's gonna happen.
We're gonna win,
this is gonna happen.
It's gonna work.
Unlike the old days of 20K when
it was all creative and it was
all organic, 5,000 in ads a
month I know what
to do with on Facebook.
I know what to do
with influencers.
We've got all these
accounts at fucking (groans).
This is real. I'm not
fucking gaining 10,000
fucking followers
on Instagram a day.
- [Nate] You have a lot
of overhead around you.
You have a lot of dedicated
people around you.
It's not cheap to
run your brand.
- [Gary] Me?
- Yes.
- [Gary] No, I know but I think
the team that we have could run
four for that
price of 15 to 20K,
I think we can run four.
- You're also producing
way more content.
- Way more.
Local papers, local
bloggers, local influencers.
It's all in my head, I got it.
I just got to put pen to paper.
We got this.
We can really win this game.
You got me?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Good, I'm done.
It was a tough day.
A lot of shit going on.
See ya.
("Better For It" by Foreign Air)